make sure you're in the frame make sure
you're in the frame okay
hi i'm ryan and i'm marie and uh today
i'm gonna be seeing uh who am i watching
uh
daily grace daily grace see here's the
thing
i don't know that many uh youtube
users youtube people whatever you call
us
whatever you call us famous people out
there me and my
huge channel i have right now marie stay
in the frame
you know she doesn't know [ __ ] about
filmmaking and that is why she is never
in the damn frame when i bring her on i
don't know that many youtubers like all
i know is jeremy johns
you know he's pretty famous for you know
doing movie reviews but i'm talking
about people have like you know
millions of subscribers and [ __ ] like
those there's like people in like their
late teens early 20s who are like making
millions of dollars a year
for some reason i was like not
interested and marie's going gonna guide
me through some of the famous people
because i don't know their names and i
want to do a google search on it i've
seen these people like once or twice
but i know their names okay so we're
gonna watch the daisy grace what daily
grace daily grace
daily grace i don't know [ __ ] about what
she does this is gonna be just me
watching whatever it is
i've seen like one of her videos and i
actually don't know what her thing is
whoa don't spoil anything quirky i think
that just might be her oh
you just gave away too much way too much
mr [ __ ] bruce willis died at the end
of the whole nine yards
daily grace let's see what you're like
is that blurred out because she's naked
i think so
hey guys hey happy monday to all of you
um she's pretty cute all right i haven't
gotten a lot of sleep this weekend she
says that
but look at how well her hair is done
like on purpose she's
awesome and my hair does not just stand
up like that
ever monday
and um yeah so
let's vlog let's do it let's talk about
things and life and etc
and um
oh she's even cuter with glasses now her
hair looks
like hey guys happy monday do you ever
have those dreams where you're doing
something and then you look down you'll
realize you've been
clearly naked oh my god
guys are you still in the shade
hey guys
oh
she is really cute right i think that's
why i think that's what she does it's
just to be cute
she's just picking random [ __ ] from her
bedroom
wow she's really sexy you guys don't
feel like you're waking up from a dream
that you can't escape or a nightmare
that you can't escape
[ __ ] it i don't care i don't care hey
guys happy monday
have a great monday i don't know if i'm
awake or asleep right now
i don't know what's going on but have a
great monday
screw it screw it i'd screw something
why don't i have dreams about hanging
hot dudes
happy monday guys
no she's really cool man yeah i'm
totally subscribed she's charming
totally subscribing to that channel
she has 2 million subscribers wow more
than 2 million
damn imagine the money she's rolling in
rich and
famous i better build up my credibility
on youtube
i want to be the kind of celebrity where
i am like
you know someone who has a career on the
rise but then i marry someone
who is significantly more famous than me
so i am just known as that person's
husband
that's what i want with daily grace
what's up baby